hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slow-mo
guys popcorn pretty entertaining food to
make top 10 probably oh easily yeah I
reckon it is the most entertaining food
to make how could it be better well how
about adding explosions with this guy
watch out it's not loaded is it no it's
not load flagged by a popcorn machine
you have to be pretty careful with these
this is a traditional Chinese popcorn
maker um you find them with Street
vendors in China essentially it's like a
pressure cooker but for popcorn yeah
usually you'd blast popcorn into a bag M
and we thought well last some all over
the Quarry and see when it expands is it
all happening here or will you see
popcorn coming out and inflating on the
way out ever use one before no I haven't
actually but it does look more lethal
than a regular pressure cooker cuz one
at home you just push the buttons and it
does its thing and you're like yeah and
then you slowly vent it you don't you
don't vent it in 01 second no you don't
vent it in0 like your food doesn't
explode out of the pressure cooker when
you do it oh bolog is
ready got our popcorn I've just sort of
been letting it soak a a little bit get
bit more extra moisture in there what's
it soaking in just water now the
instructions say half food is
enough so I assume that means half fill
it
okay I've seen them Chuck a couple of
drops of oil in I think it's for flavor
I don't think you'd want this flavor but
there we go it's just vegetable oil got
to tighten this bad boy up so now we
should just be ready to start heating it
to be honest how do you know when it's
ready well there's a pressure gauge on
here and it says most food is cooked
between 8 and 9 if it goes above 10 then
this pressure gauge released here on the
front will uh relieve the pressure so
not to worry so as a safety mechanism
w're over pressure yeah basically so it
say that' be a pretty nasty frag grenade
wouldn't it yeah I mean this is pretty
solid metal I've got quite a lot of
confidence in it to be fair okay either
way I cannot advise trying this at home
we're at 1,000 frames a second on the
4K 10,000 frames a second on the
t4040 we're starting to get some
pressure raising there look oh yeah
we're at one bar one whole bar already
yeah that's pretty good you basically
just never have one hot spot I can't
actually hear what you're saying cuz uh
this is really loud I'm just checking
nothing hang on I'll do a few reactions
for you yeah oh wow
yeah oh interesting
yeah uh no she
didn't good
enough I think we're
cooked steaming I can see it's steaming
a little
bit say when you're ready oh say when
you're ready
y oh what
happened well it went it just
went I was just like one one pop for all
your popcor wow it started to uh I think
the pressure was still Rising did you
see the coming out the top that must
have been when it got to 10 yeah that
blasted the safety valve there yeah look
at what it it's weird shape isn't it
well it's like hindered pop oh it's like
puffed corn puffed corn it's like puffed
it yeah wonder if you can make Rice
Krispies in this just Chuck rice in and
make like rice puffs yeah I was a little
bit worried cuz something came flying
back then I realized it was just a
handle I
had boom oh that is such a spread that
is it it's like a like a
saof it's like a saof with giant pellets
in it who wants popcorn everyone all
right
boom Oh did it hit the caram it did I
think we had we had a few bounces off
the top of the camera we made it that's
some range on it just like you fire a
Mor fire in the
hole wow look at the steam God that is
an explosion look at the steam like
Trails coming off the popcorn you can
see why it went so far hope half it went
up got like it's gone in all different
directions oh I just so much of it all
at once look what it did to the O-ring
oh my goodness yeah so it just swung
open so hard it just got hit by so much
stuff it got like drug over the edge
yeah
drug you the tight shows you I thought
it would be still expanding on its way
out that's what I thought too you almost
need like a glass one it's it's just
such a good illustration of pressure and
a sudden release of it too yeah is is
this the furthest piece that's a pretty
far piece that is some distance it's
serious dist I I've known people to
throw less distance than that so it must
expand literally the second air rushes
in it's expanding the the moisture
within the popcorn kernel rather than
sort of heating it from the outside in
it's just the whole thing is just
vaporizing on the inside basically it's
like causing the vapor to expand the
entire thing that's I think we should do
that again and we'll get a wider
shot
3 two
1 bang somethingone flew towards me did
it is that a piece of popcorn or
something more Sinister it's got to be a
piece of popcorn oh well that's all
right
then I love on this one you can also see
the pressure gauge oh yeah no pressure
at all got some absolute distance on it
look at the amount of stuff that came
out of that it's like Barry Poppins
bag all that it's like Doctor Who's
purse yeah it's like a little Tardis
like Harry Potter's like tent or
whatever is that is that the piece that
came towards you right at me just one
piece by my head you're right you going
to be okay if that went straight in my
mouth though that would have been the
quickest I've ever eaten fresh popcorn
that'd be a new world
record
oh is that a better bit that
unbelievable really way better than we
did can a bit yeah just uh this one
looks like a good one wellp that in on
the floor oh oh that's yeah I told
you isn't that better it's like cereal
that's better wow you just add sugar to
that and you got you're you're
billionaire do you have the honey Mon's
number I do actually give him a bell
well he's a boomer so he won't answer
his
phone I'm going to put the same sort of
amount of rice in so this will either be
a nice way to make Rice Krispies or
it'll just be a Nice Rice
shotgun snap crackling
bang you think we should fire it into a
cormer I have to go back to the shops
and get a cormer
now 3 2
1 it did it are you serious did it it's
it's
Crispies look at that wow it's it's Rice
Krispies sort of this is a culinary
Channel
now yeah crunchy edible what does it
taste like mildly burnt Rice Krispies
wow but just slightly
chewy that was a perfect one
yeah how do you think I'm performing as
your left hand today uh about as well as
my left
hand which
is not my favorite hand
it's not puffing like a a void inside
Feel Like Rice Krispies are often Hollow
yeah they're more Hollow this is kind of
like a um an even puff well that's quite
the transformation it is I was expecting
less and I don't know why but I just
thought that would be hot fast rice so
did I I thought it would be really quick
hot rice but I'm actually impressed
yeah
look at that they were fting to get out
it seems like it's it's like puking them
out it's like it's absolutely boking out
the rice that's the biggest rice Bo I've
ever
seen it was definitely speedier than the
pop I feel like it was more like boky
than the popcorn the popcorn was more
gentle than that well I think the
popcorn because of air resistance is
going to slow down down almost
immediately but that that Rice just went
well success I think um there two idiots
trying to Puff stuff in a thing they've
never used that wasn't bad we made some
uh two types of burnt food I liked burnt
food one a lot better I think you think
burnt food I would eat a whole bag of
the popcorn you would yeah I mean it's
very different to regular popcorn isn't
it yeah I didn't realize there was
another format for a maze kernel yeah I
was I was impressed I think if I was
ranking them I would do popcorn for
flavor yeah and rice for distance for
distance is that an important category
in food for some
people okay I'm just going to go popcorn
I think the rice needs a bit more
development but stay tuned well
hopefully you enjoyed that video as much
as Dan enjoyed his new style of popcorn
make sure you subscribe if you like
slow-mo and uh I think I'll give you a
week off from hitting the like button
this time um instead of doing that just
sort of relax and maybe watch nine or 10
of our other videos yeah make yourself a
cup of tea sit down put your feet up
chill out here's one
yeah